[Music]
i need one room
look if you're uh pissed at me maybe we
should get separate rooms you get your
own room i need a major credit card
all right
i have uh
diners
visa
and a gasoline card
everyone has the day off work there's a
big bird on the table and relatives that
you haven't seen in a while are sitting
around watching parades and football
happy thanksgiving everyone now
obviously thanksgiving doesn't have
quite the rich cinematic tradition that
certain other holidays have enjoyed but
we've still watched the fourth thursday
in november unfold on the big screen
enough times to inspire us to look back
at some of the most noteworthy not so
thankful thanksgivings in movie history
[Music]
we've gathered together an eclectic
group for our list including old
favorites indie upstarts and even a
critical duo or two so tuck in your
napkins wait for sis to say grace and
let's all dig in as we count down the
most disastrous movie thanksgivings
[Music]
starting with number 10 the doors the
surviving members of the doors disputed
a lot of the material that ended up in
oliver stone's wildly over-the-top jim
morrison biopic this includes the
infamous scene that depicts the late
doris front man locking girlfriend
pamela corson in a closet and setting it
on fire and the thanksgiving dinner
sequence in which patricia connealy the
woman who may or may not have been his
wife ends up throwing the turkey at
morrison starring val kilmer meg ryan
kevin dillon and directed by oliver
stone critics say val kilmer delivers a
powerhouse performance as one of rock's
most incendiary figures but
unfortunately oliver stone is unable to
shed much light on the circus
surrounding the star
trisha hi jim hey
um
pam do you have you met do you know have
you
she wrote this great review of my poetry
book
jim why don't we go eat that derpy huh
come on pam let's go set those plates
patricia caneli are you patricia canelli
you must be pamela
you actually put your in this woman jim
well
sometimes yeah
well i understand i really do but just
don't you ever expect that jim's gonna
love you or take care of you because
you're one of a hundred you know hey
come on you don't know when to stop
look who's talking well i like to think
that jim can make up his own mind about
who he loves and who he doesn't well
don't kid yourself sweetheart he's crazy
but he's not that crazy he loves me come
on pam let's go check on those sweet
potatoes
number nine the house of yes this is
another unbearably awkward thanksgiving
so the house of yes finds tori
spelling's character joining her
fiance's family for the meal she meets
them for the first time only to discover
that his relationship with his mentally
unstable twin sister is much more
complex than she'd been led to believe
matter of fact pretty much everyone in
the family has something lurking under
the surface and much of it will become
known to poor torii before the weekend
is over and did we mention that there's
a hurricane going on during all of this
don't feel too bad for misspelling
though because for one of the only times
in her career she actually earned some
of the movie's highest marks starring
tori spelling parker posey josh hamilton
and directed by mark waters richard
corliss from time magazine says bejold
has the frazzled hator of an aging
neglected star and spelling is nicely
glazed studiously artless but the film
is key to posey's performance perfectly
brittle thoughtlessly false i know what
else you did
i know where the scar came from and i
know why they sent you that hospital
you're a regular nancy drew you're
making him crazy
you want to make him crazy like you
look at yourself
look at your clothes
you're making fun of a woman who lost
her husband
a man died a man was murdered man who
did something for other people what have
you ever done for somebody else
you really love marty
think about what his life will be like
here in this house
your mom will die
you'll be left alone
you'll have babies with web feet you
have to bury out back in the yard
hi
where in the yard
where
we're exactly in the yard marty where do
you think we should bury these babies
with webbed feet the backyard's getting
rather crowded with corpses first
daddies and now duck babies you killed
your father
at me mama my father left my mother
years ago the day kennedy was shot he
tried to leave but mama shot him we
bared him by the central air they were
installing central air there was a hole
in the ground but not for him for the
air conditioner she's confused you're
confused jackie he left mama he called a
cab she covered him with her body she
tried to keep him there jackie kennedy
not mama jackie kennedy she tried to
keep his head on but it was falling off
leslie go get my suitcase
leslie
[Music]
sorry about all this
number eight home for the holidays
unlike some of the films on this list
home for the holidays doesn't rely on
thanksgiving as a backdrop or a plot
device it's actually the whole reason
for the movie in jody foster's second
directorial outing holly hunter plays a
beleaguered single mom whose life is
falling apart just in time for a holiday
feast with her highly dysfunctional
family despite a solid cast not to
mention a november release date and
generally favorable reviews holidays
failed to gain much traction at the box
office starring holly hunter robert
downey jr and bancroft and directed by
jody foster critics say much like a real
life visit home for the holidays this
thanksgiving set dramedy can get a
little bumpy but it also has its share
of fondly memorable moments
i'm trying to get an angle so would you
spot weld this mom
[Laughter]
baking soda bacon
[Music]
oh
look at this look at your father's time
it's useless i know how you feel
you don't know how i feel in my opinion
you don't even care well opinions are
like
everybody's got one and everybody thinks
everybody else's stinks
[Laughter]
[Music]
number seven alice's restaurant
only in the 60s could an 18-minute
talking blues song by a 19 year old
white kid from new england become such a
big hit that it inspired a movie helmed
by an a-list director like arthur penn
but that's exactly what happened with
arlo guthrie's alice's restaurant in a
rambling tale of a pair of massachusetts
hippies who found themselves dragged to
court for illegally dumping garbage on
thanksgiving day only to watch the
arresting officer break down in tears of
frustration when he discovers that the
presiding judge is blind and can't see
the glossy color photos meticulously
taken of the scene of the crime as a
movie alice's restaurant is arguably
most interesting as a 60s relic or an
early example of meta filmmaking with
the real life alice making a cameo and
officer william obie obenhein stars as
himself starring arlo guthrie patricia
quinn james broderick and directed by
arthur penn jacob brackman from esquire
magazine says at one end i suppose to
judge alice's a brilliantly inventive
attor vision personal topical hilarious
deeply pessimistic at the other to judge
alice's a dog a messy porridge in the
middle reservations and 14 point
checklist
[Music]
[Applause]
much
ratings
[Music]
thank you so much wow this is wonderful
isn't it great
i made the turkey she made the platter
wonder who made her no one i know about
you wouldn't have had to try
how about grace yeah grace
praise be to alice for coming home to
cook this beast
for being here to dig in
because we're beautiful
now we're doing it yeah
we go what we need
what more do we want
pastures of plenty come on dig in
[Applause]
welcome back to ron tomatoes countdown
here is our list so far of the most
disastrous movie thanksgivings
[Music]
number six adam's family values for many
the adams family movies trigger memories
of mchammer more than anything else but
1993's adam's family values actually
received better reviews than its
predecessor the movie is also noteworthy
for containing one of the most
hysterical thanksgiving pageants in
movie history it begins with turkeys
singing eat me and culminates with
christina ritchie's wednesday adams
playing pocahontas departing from the
script written by unctuous summer camp
director gary granger to air a list of
grievances against the pilgrims before
directing her tribe to burn their
village to the ground now it might read
like a tryptophan-induced dream of
howard zinn's but it's actually very
funny starring angelica houston raul
julia christina ritchie and directed by
barry sonnenfeld critics say new
well-developed characters add dimension
to this batty satire creating a comedy
much more substantial than the original
the gods of my tribe have spoken they
have said do not trust the pilgrims
especially
sarah miller
gary she's changing the words and for
all these reasons
i've decided to scalp you
and burn your village to the ground
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
he's not a team player he's a special
child but he needs friends do you need
friends like this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
number five pieces of april
2003's pieces of april is about a woman
who invites her estranged family to her
apartment to meet her boyfriend over
thanksgiving dinner the film did okay at
the box office but critics applauded the
film sending screenwriter peter hedges
his directorial debut all the way up to
84 on the tomato meter somewhat
stereotypically for an indie production
nothing much really happens in pieces of
april but given that holm spends much of
the film struggling to get dinner made
it could be said that this is one of the
few movies on this list that accurately
captures the culinary drama behind the
holiday starring katie holmes patricia
clarkson oliver platt and directed by
peter hedges critics say pieces of april
transcends its small scale setting and
budget with endearing performances
playful humor and genuine sweetness
resulting in a touching holiday treat
i was knocking on a lot of doors looking
for you
yours was a jar
i'm in
how's it going
no foreseeable problems
i was about to check your turkey myself
then i thought
since it's yours maybe you'd prefer to
do the checking
okay
i certainly could do it for you
and will if you'd like
didn't want to
presume fine whatever
it's a common misconception that you can
just stick a turkey in the oven
turkey needs to be tended to he needs to
be cared for lovingly
one must pay close attention to poultry
sure
so much can go wrong
turkey could burn in places be
overcooked undercooked which is a health
hazard and what about basting look wayne
i'll be up in a second okay
a second
just give me a minute
tick tock
number four the ice storm
what do angly and christina richie have
against thanksgiving anyway in her
second appearance on this list richie
plays windy hood one in the series of
cynical borderline misanthropic teens
that she portrayed in the 90s and in a
slight albeit far less humorous echo of
her turn as wednesday adams in adam's
family values but she uses thanksgiving
as an opportunity to lift the veil on
the holiday's darker side delivering a
soliloquy about the inherent cruelty of
the celebration painful to watch
indubitably and appropriately for a film
that hinges on crushing on wii and
alienation lee who also directed
brokeback mountain received high marks
for adapting rick moody's tense sad
novel about suburban families in the 70s
starring kevin klein joan allen
christina ritchie and directed by ang
lee critics say director angley revisits
the enwy late in decadence of 1970
suburban america with deft humor and
gripping pathos
well it's great that we can all be
together
and this thanksgiving no uh yelling no
hysteria especially with your grandpa
not here
although we miss him
so let's do it right and wendy uh why
don't you say grace
you still love to say grace remember
[Music]
dear lord
thank you for this thanksgiving holiday
and for all the material possessions
that we have and enjoy and for letting
us white people kill all the indians and
steal their tribal lands and
stuff ourselves like pigs even though
children asia are being neighborhood
jesus enough all right
paul
roll
thank you gravy
number three brokeback mountain
thanksgiving like any family holiday can
be something of a double-edged blade it
has the potential to both bring loved
ones together but in doing so it also
has the ability to exacerbate tensions
and given that the protagonists in
english brokeback mountains spend their
adult lives struggling with their barely
expressed love for one another you might
expect that turkey and mashed potatoes
would serve as a garnish for some
remarkably tense moments you'd be right
too because both ennis and jack suffer
through some bleak thanksgivings none
more awkward than the one which acts as
a prelude to ennis wife alma confronting
him about a secret affair
awkward starring heath ledger jake
gyllenhaal michelle williams and
directed by ang lee critics say a
beautiful epic western brokeback
mountain's love story is imbued with
heartbreaking universality thanks to
moving performances by heath ledger and
jake gyllenhaal
bobby
if you don't eat your dinner i'm gonna
have to turn off that television why
mama i want to be in this room for the
next two weeks hey you heard your mama
you finish your meal and then you can
watch again
daddy
daddy
hail
we don't
eat with our eyes
i want your boy to grow up to be a man
don't you daughter
boy should watch football
not until
he finishes eating a meal
that his mama took three hours
this is my house
this is my child and you are my guest
you sit down before i knock your
ignorance in the next week
welcome back to ron tomatoes countdown
here is our list so far of the most
disastrous movie thanksgivings
[Music]
number two hannah and her sisters
ah thanksgiving what would it be without
turkey stuffing cranberry sauce and
lustfully eyeing your wife's sister
actually most of us wouldn't know about
that last item on the list but for
michael kane and woody allen's hannah
and her sisters it's a different story
the film opens with keynes elliott
conducting some
hand
allen-esque
over his secret crush on his
sister-in-law lee who he takes every
opportunity to bump into around town and
it all makes for a rather uncomfortable
holiday for elliot starring mia farrow
michael kane and woody allen who also
directed the film critics say smart
tender and funny in equal measure hannah
and her sisters is one of woody allen's
finest films
god she's beautiful
she's got the prettiest eyes
and she looks so sexy in that sweat
i just want to be alone with her and
hold her and kiss her and tell her how
much i love her and take care of her
stop it you idiot she's your wife's
sister
i can't help it
i'm consumed by her
it's been months now
i dream about it i i think about her at
the office
holy
what am i gonna do
i hear myself mooning over you
and it's disgusting
before when she squeezed past me in the
doorway and i smelled that perfume on
the back of her neck
jesus i i thought i was gonna swoon
easy
you're a dignified financial advisor
it doesn't look good for you to spoil it
oh yeah
hell yeah sweetheart
have you tried these these are wonderful
holly and her friend made them
look fantastic right your sister is an
unbelievable cook no one no she has all
the cooking time
and finally number one planes trains and
automobiles perhaps the quintessential
thanksgiving film planes trains and
automobiles represent a critical and
commercial high point for all of its
principles now this includes steve
martin as repressed ad executive neil
page john candy as unintentionally
obnoxious shower curtain ring salesman
del griffith and john hughes as the
writer and director of a film not
starring molly ringwald now on its face
there's very little about planes to
distinguish it from other films i mean
how many 80s movies feature an uptight
ad exec going on some kind of
transformative journey anyway and where
john hughes goes broad humor inevitably
follows but martin and candy play off
one another brilliantly and if any movie
deserves to have a big gooey heart
beating at its center shouldn't it be
one about the true meaning of
thanksgiving starring steve martin john
candy lila robbins and directed by john
hughes critics say thanks to the
impeccable chemistry between steve
martin and john candy as well as a depth
mix of humor and heart planes trains and
automobiles is a hilarious heartfelt
holiday classic you're going the wrong
way
what you're going the wrong way
he says we're going the wrong way oh
he's drunk
how would he know where we're going
yeah how would he know
thank you thanks a lot
terrific thank you
[Music]
what a [ __ ]
[Music]
you're going in the wrong direction
you're going to kill somebody
[Music]
you're going the wrong way
what
[Music]
and friends that about does it for us be
sure to stay tuned to the rotten
tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content that you love and
for even more news scores and
recommendations on the latest tv shows
and movies head on over to
rottentomatoes.com until next time i'm
your host naz perez and we'll see you
back here for more top 10s on the rotten
tomatoes countdown
[Music]
you